look at Santa Claus bicha the hell are
you looking at Mesa five four
sorry Santa I had to go how you thought
it was me
we got a job Willy I'm talking me off
this time
goddamn associate who's got this thing
all lined up what's it been 15 years
mom well you still hit like your daddy
Deanie wait you don't trust your mother
yeah trust her about as far as I can
throw you trust you about as far as I
could throw her
mm I don't even know you how to mom I
think I was just hatched I traveled
across the country to rob a charity you
got a problem with that you're damn
right I got a problem with it no way
these [ __ ] have two million bucks
tell me let's go tap
what is he doing it elf you got smaller
I even got minis for the Munchkin don't
you ever call me that you got a problem
with that you take it up with a lollipop
Gil
hello cash only ten dollars or more
hundreds are better look at those cheeks
it's the ugliest baby on the planet
damn hi I'm Diane welcome to giving city
ain't exactly what you call the romantic
type but I gotta tell you you got
gigantic skew see you need a holiday
starting to feel like Christmas
miserable both of you sometimes I need
to be bad you don't have real family you
gotta make a new one and I know you're
not the Santa but you're still my Santa
Merry Christmas
one time I ate too much turkey bacon I
didn't poop for two weeks for four weeks
this your spawn do I look like I made
him well if this ain't fetal alcohol
syndrome then what is it
your robber god damn charity got an
associate who's got this thing all lined
up what associate [ __ ] steak mom you
still hit like your [ __ ]